while staggering new figures reveal the
extent of the damage to the world's
biggest economy by the coronavirus
shutdown in just one week
another six point six million people
filed for unemployment benefits that
means nearly 17 million Americans have
lost their jobs in the past three weeks
that's around one in ten workers for
more on this let's turn to our White
House correspondent Kimberley halket
she's live for us from Washington DC
Kimberly how much of a shiver are these
numbers sending down the spine of the
economy there well they were expected
but still the numbers are staggering
never before in US history has there
been such a significant job loss in such
a short amount of time the numbers are
simply astounding because as you point
out we've had three consecutive weeks
now of massive job losses in just three
weeks more than 17 million Americans
have lost their jobs and what we're told
as the numbers are actually much higher
Sammy but the states can't keep up with
the number of claims in other words
people can't get through on the phone to
even file the claims so we expect when
all is said and done that more than 46
million Americans are going to file for
unemployment hits across all sectors
whether it's office workers whether it's
hospitality industry even the health
care industry because while the United
States pivots and prioritizes dealing
with kovat 19 many other areas like for
example elective surgeries or other
specialties even like dental work is all
being put to the side so many of these
health care workers are also finding
themselves having to file these claims
and again the numbers truly historic in
terms of modern history at the same time
the Trump administration taking some
flak for the depleting stocks of the
national strategic reserve tell us why
yeah this has been an ongoing criticism
that not only is there sort of a lack of
awareness of what's available but that
it's not getting to who needs it in
terms of personal protective equipment
things like surgical masks gloves the
gowns that these frontline First
Responder health care workers need to
deal with coronavirus and so the new
concern is this national stockpile the
strategic national stockpile is as it's
known essentially what we're being told
is that 90 percent of the stockpile has
been dispersed and they're not going to
give any more because they're keeping
ten percent for the federal government
in its response so where is it going
it's going to state and local
governments now this is a criticism that
has Democrats on Capitol Hill
particularly unhappy they're pointing
the Trump administration saying you're
in charge of the federal response and
what you've left these states and local
governments to do now is to essentially
get into bidding war scouring the open
market and in fact we've seen even on
social media frontline workers taking
pictures of themselves wearing garbage
bags in place out these protective gowns
that normally they would use now the
Trump administration is defending its
response saying it's the fault of the
states they should have been better
prepared but I can tell you it's not
just the in terms of shortages in the
United States it's not exclusive to just
personal protective equipment in fact
ordinary Americans are finding when they
go to the grocery stores things they
count on like toilet paper even canned
goods are also scarce are hard to find
even not at all so this is an issue that
is ongoing and as I pointed out again
already there is this finger pointing
towards the Trump administration so far
it is deflecting blame all right it's a
clearly difficult situation than the the
latest unemployment numbers only add to
that what is the Federal Reserve
planning to do about it
well the Federal Reserve is a body that
is a monetary body in terms of interest
rates and the rest but in terms of the
response with regard to personal
protective equipment this is something
that is an ongoing crisis now if you
watch the briefings in the White House
briefing room they will tell you that
everything's great it's under control
we've never seen something like this
before and we're doing the best we can
but I can tell you we've seen some
unusual characters popping in to take
control of this situation for example
the president's son-in-law Jared Kushner
who obviously has no expertise when it
comes to dispatching equipment to in
emergency situations his real estate
background certainly does not make him
especially equip for handling this
crisis and yet that's one of the the
people that the president now has
overseeing this and in fact he did have
a bit of a slip up this week in terms of
even understanding the basics of how the
the strategic reserve worked and as a
result there's been a lot of criticism
that this is an administration that
simply doesn't know what it's doing and
it is evident in terms of the lack of
materials that are out in the states and
local governments now all right Kimberly
haki there thanks for that